hey what's up y'all this easy mail and
check me out on the bootleg Kev podcast
we got a special guest in here easy Mill
what's good Kev so you're uh you're born
in the Philippines but you're kind of
from Vegas is that what I gather yeah
yeah I used to live in Vegas so that's
crazy like where uh off of Craig and the
15. that's why it's like the north side
ah North where'd you go to high school
out out there
um High School way did you go to high
school in Vegas oh no uh in the
Philippines oh you okay so when you move
like what point of time in your life
were you like I'm going to pick up and
move to Vegas uh it wasn't necessarily
like my decision to like a family
related thing but um so it was around
like I would say like 16. okay 17.
runtime like right when I dropped out of
like
like the second Sim of my college okay
yeah like right when I dropped out like
my papers was processed for like uh so
probably 17 yeah I was 17 when I came
today so you get to Vegas and then it's
melting hot and you're like why did we
move here man I have a funny story about
that actually
So I entered through Seattle okay I
stayed there for a week because my
family was there like on my grandma's
side and then uh finally got with my
immediate family like my mom's sisters
and everybody in L.A so we was out here
for a year
and prices just got a little too
expensive and that's why you went to
Vegas prices are still getting a little
too expensive
and I feel like Vegas getting hit with
that too it is for sure it's definitely
I mean now you guys got the Raiders
there's like a basketball prize on the
way the Clippers too somebody's coming
yeah I don't know if it's gonna be a
Clipper somebody's coming
did you perform at a Clippers game yes
sir that got to be cool yeah are you a
basketball fan
um I wouldn't say like through and
through I am but definitely admire the
sport respectively right yeah it was
Filipino night
yeah Filipino Heritage night when you go
to Filipino Heritage night
um have you ever ran into a
little tiny fat round man named Brian
Sampson no I'm good all right just gonna
make sure I'm sure Ross gonna introduce
you to him he's like everyone's like
Filipino uncle in the music industry oh
yeah he's just stay away he gets you in
trouble he'll get you in trouble all
right okay
um how long have you been like actually
like really taking the music profession
serious like
um it was
right when I dropped out to in the
Philippines like right at that
transition like um right when I dropped
out I started making metal music like
full time
and then basically like I would say like
in the to the world's eyes where they
would say I took it seriously it's like
when I got to the states and started
trying to rap to sing so you're doing
like metal yeah like [__] like give
me like a comparison to the death core
technical death core technical death
metal brutal death core the whole death
Spectrum Jesus so would that be like
Slayer type [__] the um because I know
there's a bunch of sub genres yes
there's like industrial you're actually
right on the money because Slater Slayer
if it wasn't for them death will
wouldn't exist right they're kind of
like the Run DMC of death metal
thrash metal they're thrashed yeah yeah
no so what's what's the biggest death
metal band
I would say dying fetus I heard a dying
fetus yeah they Cannibal Corpse Cannibal
Corpse yeah them that [__] is have you
ever heard of uh
is it job for a cowboy Oh Yeah now
they're legendary death core death metal
people still like you know debate about
this yo listen I was driving uh me and
my boy TK who's a producer of mine who
works for me and he we were driving from
Phoenix to LA in the middle of the night
he had to stay awake and I was supposed
to take a nap
so we swapped seats and he throws on
yeah drop for is it drop her account for
a cowboy yeah
that's the kind of [__] you were making
oh my God that is
yo I literally was like bro what the
[__] is going on right now like what is
even going on right now so you were
doing like the room
wow yep [__] salute full time so you
were like you bet been in a lot of uh
like [__] mosh pits yeah
unfortunately
mosh pits are um they're fun I just saw
I mean I just saw Metallica the other
day and and obviously they're kind of
like not death metal they're quite the
opposite
but there was tons of pits still going
on throughout the whole like floor and I
was like oh this reminds me of high
school right yeah but I'm sure the pizza
it goes Death Metal Show are a little
bit more aggressive it's crazy it's like
there's a whole lot of like mental
stress that actually goes on with like
actually even the artist that goes into
it because it takes a different kind of
like a set of group who would want to
see like you know the violence ensue
right in front of their eyes yeah
that's actually what happens when even
the guitar just starts like damn
[__] everybody start smiling oh my God
so is there a big scene for that in the
Philippines
pretty small pretty very very small
that's why when I started like kind of
grinding for it like I had to kind of
put like this layer on my figure like
how to approach the fan base because
because it would just be like
white boys like from here SoCal and in
Norway sometimes yeah yeah yeah there I
think there's a uh it correct me if I'm
wrong wasn't there a death metal band
that one of the members killed one of
the other members in Adam
um I don't know about or is that was
that or was that like a
they probably don't tell they use the uh
album art for they talking about yeah
Mayhem I don't know uh that's a black
metal actually black metal yeah black
metal that is that from Norway yeah yes
and there's a big band that's uh what's
the big band that's [__] yeah I think
it was Mayhem Mayhem the band Mayhem
they use the uh his bandmate's body took
a picture of it in his album art
yeah that's hardcore for real yeah I see
why you're into it man
yeah so how do you end up being this kid
who could dance and rap it what
uh man it was like
I've been
that has just been kind of like an
escape thing growing up you know
like cause I'd be stressed out too much
stressing too much about school and like
all of the homework and and being at
home always getting scolded and
she was with my sisters like in in China
I was in the Philippines
and um yeah so a lot of the times like
at school I wouldn't be too good in like
you know the academic stuff but when
like PE go on like we got a project like
we need to do some dance thing all right
let's go right I'm like that type and
basically that's like kind of just been
what I'm doing but never took it like to
I did take it seriously
because like in Elementary in sixth
grade nonsense
fifth grade I I was actually doing dance
competitions with like some of my
classmates
and yeah but it was like on some real
thug and dance since like like how job
Milwaukee's could have came up but in
the Philippines yeah some real battles
but like some like you were like you're
like bandaged up from the mosh pit from
the night before yeah and then you had
to go and [__] yeah actually dance
yep that's crazy it's just a dope uh
pendulum you're on like you could you
did Death Metal and you were you know
dancing for real because you were
dancing you you had you got opportunity
to dance with the Jabbawockeez right yes
I actually
um had the opportunity to dance with the
ex-founders uh his name Phil Taya Goyo
Phil he was the one I um choreographer
choreographed my video for my song up
down which is out right now y'all can
check that out is that the song that I
call Eminem's attention yeah yeah it's
gonna be pretty cool
um were you like did you grow up a
Eminem fan yes very much so but actually
cool story like I know I didn't get hit
to like Em's music up until
yeah you had to catch up on the old [__]
because like other than like other than
that like I will be focusing more like
the physical like kind of activities in
school so I was also in a soccer team
and like I'll be hanging out with my
cousin sometimes like the weekends and
we we're in the field and then he had
like brought like his uh little iPod at
the time and then he had lose no it
wasn't Lose Yourself when I'm gone
um and when I first listened to that and
then bleachers broke and and obal like I
was just there like
you took me to a whole story like when
when I'm gone when I'm gone just carry
on yeah
that's Eminem So you kind of you kind of
got hit his whole [__] later yeah yeah
because how old are you right now I'm
25. so you're young so you were like I
just saw 50 Cent celebrate 20 years of
get rich or die trying which was like
[__] nine years in the M M's run
eight years in them
that's crazy yeah I'm pretty sure Slim
Shady LP probably came out like the year
you were born or I would think so or
1998 yeah yeah
it's 98 or 90 yeah 98 yeah sure that's
it might have been 99. would you know
what exact like month it was I don't
know the exact month that's good we can
Google it can we google that
Slim Shady LP release date
shout out to M
um so obviously Eminem being one of the
greatest of all time
he's always signing artists I always
feel like that
have a very high skill level so when
people say oh Eminem signed a new artist
right they're like oh [__] I gotta go
check this out because I know this guy's
gotta gotta really get down like for you
what was the initial
did he DM you did Paul Rosenberg reach
out to you like what was the initial
contact point of contact there so 99
cents
right after I was yeah yeah so like how
it happened was
um right when we dropped up down the
music video like
four days three days after that
um Paul emailed us ffp and my girl read
it and she thought it was like fake at
first because how he formatted it like
sure it had Shady Goliath records yeah
um how can I get in contact with easy
new but it's like kind of like the homie
wrote it up you feel me yeah so it's
like nah that can't be real she was like
somebody scam emails getting the same
yeah bro and then
um I had to be our people at virgins and
kind of give us a shrug like hey yo this
for real like um there's a serious
meeting that's gonna happen and then it
wasn't like a day before that we're
gonna ride out to the meeting that they
told me
um so you're gonna be meeting Eminem
like swirling in the room bro and then
they comboed me with like when I got
back to the
what and
Dre's gonna be there too like
so your first meeting with Eminem Dr
Dre's there yeah
crazy
I want to say the last time they signed
an artist together besides 50 it was a
guy named stat quo stat quo they had
stack quote for a sec oh he was from
Atlanta
now he manages uh shout out Atlanta how
he manages lyrical lemonade
but now it's crazy man so what was that
like were you nervous were you [__]
like did you tell them about your death
metal past oh yeah well I did actually
yo like that's crazy because I was so
nervous like I don't know if that's even
the right word for what's a more
nervousness nervous level of nervousness
that I can pinpoint
but yes so at that point man like Dre
was sitting on the couch like kind of in
a Lobby like that in the studio right
here and he stood up when I went in like
hey Superstar what
said to me you what you're Dr Dre well
yeah so and then I kept walking then I
went to like the angle to see in the
door and I saw him sitting at the edge
well I like spend again like in
disbelief and then I kept walking though
and then he stood up when I walked to
the door of the studio he was like
Ezekiel
where you been the last 20 years
oh right you were four what was he what
was he like for you like what was the
one thing he communicated to you
obviously we know the song that he saw
that kind of you know he shared that um
but what was what was it about you that
he said that like he really gravitated
towards
um
so at first he said
man your lines like you definitely like
spit them and you talking your [__] and
we just [__] with it man and then you
can sing and dance too like when I found
out about you like you're like who the
[__] is this that's like me imitating
how he was saying yeah
that's how they kind of will get down
and then so I just took it to Dre now I
called him up and then Jay was like this
and like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's crazy all right we gotta stop the
interview real quick tell you about our
folks at my bookie our partners at my
bookie man listen football season is
approaching it is preseason right now I
can feel it just had my first Fantasy
Draft it's time to get this [__]
money NFL is here go to mybookie.ag
right now sign up for a new account use
the promo code bootleg right now when
you sign up they're gonna give you that
first deposit bonus now my book is crazy
because no matter where you're at you
can go on and get in on some of that NFL
action you can get on some of that
baseball action you can get in on their
Live casino
Blackjack roulette slots whatever you're
into it's going down mybookie.ag all
right sign up right now with that promo
code bootleg they're gonna hook you up
real nice first deposit bonus free money
to gamble with bro when you sign up with
we talking about football season is here
this is literally my favorite time of
the year as a degenerate we must
participate we got to get a little
action in every Sunday on something
maybe a little Thursday night football
action maybe a little pre-season action
who do you think's gonna win the Super
Bowl throw 100 on it [__] it sign up
mybookie.edu use that promo code bootleg
and they're going to get you hooked up
with that first deposit bonus also want
to give a big shout out to our family at
King Palm man want to give a shout out
to King Palm they have the um sugar Sean
first of all congratulations to Phoenix
Arizona's own sugar Shawn for just
winning that title with UFC they did a
collab with them
uh these are the sugar punch honey
orange pre-rolls which are gas all right
now this was dope about King Palm 100
organic all right we're talking about no
tobacco organic leaves and what's dope
is they have these terpene infused tips
that people just love bro they're called
the flavor tips right you like uh you
bust one of these boys out you know I'm
saying you fill it with your stuff
whatever you want to smoke some of that
flour that you got from Jardine
and then you hit the tip
and man oh I just tasted it right now
just flavor full of Flavor now go to
kingpom.com right now use the promo code
bootleg and you're gonna get half off
whatever's on kingpop.com if you don't
know King Palm is everywhere go to your
local smoke shop go to your local
7-Eleven they got King Palms everywhere
so many flavors
so many Vibes the grapes are gas
yo kingpom.com use the promo code
bootleg 50 off let's get back to the
interview so are you [__] you're shady
aftermath yes sir that's [__] crazy
city after my school open the scope Hey
listen man 50 Cent I just went I just
went last night so you got it you got a
big uh
you have big shoes to fill man for that
shady aftermath flag
then they ain't done some shoes they did
some boots man they sent them yeah More
Boots more boots for sure I'm ready flat
um it's dope too because like I do feel
like the last like you know five or six
years we've seen like a dope uh you know
we got guys like pilo who are out here
who are Filipino obviously representing
the bay but I feel like uh artists who
happen to be Asian are like prospering
there's a girl named tweet it's popping
right now
um for you how important is it to make
sure like you're representing for your
Homeland at the same time as being you
know representing Eminem and Dr Dre you
know what I mean yes to me it's like
default like even when I try to spit it
just comes out naturally like it's
because
I feel like when it comes to writing
lines it just goes to show like from the
freestyle point it kind of also ask
yourself so that's all you're talking
about so where are you from and then you
say away from then it's just you already
represented without even knowing right
and then I just took that like into
perspective where I'm gonna take that
responsibility in throughout like going
forward what I've already said and you
know basically try to mature the sound
of like the music I've already created
and like you know still to stay forward
I still man how often do you go back
home or you know right now like only
flights are not yet they're very
expensive not yet again but we did for a
homecoming tour like last last year
that's yeah plus yeah yo I heard you
can't do anything out there that put you
in jail I just watched a Vice episode
about ah did you see that Vice episode
man don't be like getting to him but
if you know somebody you know somebody
don't worry if you come up I'm not
coming to the Philippines and smoking
weed see most times when I go to a
different country I'll bring weed with
me because I'll be like there I heard
they don't [__] around I heard that
President don't play around there used
to it'd be I and them jails look very
populated
they look crazy yeah
yo we were talking a little bit off
camera about uh the most I would say
like legendary Filipino Cuisine for
people who don't like eat normal [__]
you know they see like tick tocks of was
it balut
and it's uh it's it's I want to try it
I don't want to try it I feel like I
kind of have to try it it's like a half
is it a chicken
so it's a half like it's almost like a
duck embryo that's like half developed
right yeah have you had it I had it like
two times in my life how is it
um it's an acquired taste do you put hot
sauce on it
or any sort of sauce you just eat it the
way it is I would just put soy sauce soy
sauce okay let's try it
I gotta give it a shot man is it crunchy
um depends on what you would say crunchy
I'm making a tick tock out of it for
sure
for sure making a tick tock out of it
let's go I can't wait to watch that
maybe we'll do it together okay all
right yeah you'll serve it up I'll eat
it and then you know everybody can make
fun of me for
for uh what I'm sure will be a
interesting
reaction oh yeah yeah I'm putting cable
and there's some balloon hey yo so uh
you you put out this new record with am
uh realist like is that something you're
in the studio with him
or is that like a record you have like
tell me the story about that record at
first because like prior like it was
just a regular day like I was working on
songs and that was one of them okay so
the beat are you making your own beats
right yeah so you do everything
you know
you can do anything man
yeah I'll just try to hone in I'll Focus
though but you're working on that record
yeah I had the song basically the first
verse first and the chorus yeah it's
just that and then found out
we went to
you know the studio with Emma Dre that
and I showed them yeah they [__] with it
and then basically after that it was
just a pass back and forth oh wow yeah
so you get the M verse back
that's gotta be it well it's so crazy
like how like I reacted to when I first
listened to it like I was so turned
because I wanted to listen to it again
yeah and then there was like this wait
time now like now I understand
I understand what Boogie felt
what Boogie felt when he got on the song
that's a boogie man yeah West Side
Boogie West Side Boogie is amazing who
were some of your outside of M obviously
like what were some of your like uh
hip-hop influences like what were you
listening to like what are you listening
to like who are your goats like
um
Eminem Kendrick Lamar ASAP Rocky
Tech N9ne Hobson
um
Snoop Dogg
yup have you seen Tech Nine live yet
nope really
that's uh there's so much like shows
that's like the greatest man I I
wouldn't I wouldn't argue when it comes
to performing he's like the goat he got
that metal background too he's amazing
his live show is [__] sick hopson's
sick live
overall like did you see that like his
bait like recently like saying that yeah
that was cool no yeah it was smart it
went viral yeah he's smart he said
everybody you got a free chance to throw
[__] at me
and they filmed it at the right time and
it went viral yeah you ever link with
Disney ride in Vegas who's used to be
signed with Hopsin Funk Volume
um
funny story actually uh not necessarily
me in um like you know directly like one
of my homeboys that um makes Beats for
me now and I also collaborated with
Michael bars okay
he actually got in recently like
connected with him so there's nobody
MC's out there dizzy there's a kid named
Echo that's dope
um there's a bunch of dudes in Vegas in
her fire but let's talk you grew up
listening to Hopson and Tech N9 yeah you
got to see Tech live it's like [__]
it's insane yeah I want to win what's
your favorite uh Tech Nine song or album
Tech N9ne song
strangulation Cipher
with
what's his name Stevie Stone yes TV
Stone and I think Ces Cru is there SAS
crew and
also God they miss
goddamis however you say his name yeah
that one that's my favorite when I heard
that there was all just like spazzing
back to back to back to back to back you
ever heard the Eminem song that Tech did
with him
oh come on that too that [__] crazy yeah
that's for real look
that's super dope yeah yo honestly you
see him live and it'll Inspire your live
show like you're probably already
amazing live because you come from your
background that you come from and you
dance and you do so much but I'm down to
learn for real for sure like birth
control alone bro his [__] is nasty yeah
get it it's super super Gnar uh all
right so what's coming up for you
obviously you're working on are you
working on your shady aftermath debut
yes yes
um so right now
like working on songs day in day out and
like you know like continuing the drafts
and just keep piling forward and like
you know holding on the songs I already
have but also one of the focus I want to
keep going is like creating the motion
pictures for these songs
that I've already done
like for example right now Duality Redux
yes the songs where we got M on yeah MB
now
shout out to Ambi now man yeah Stockton
Stockton
also Filipino mm-hmm yeah everything
else though yo was he here yeah he's
been here I've interviewed him a few
times oh that's crazy good guy good guy
man great guy hey Hey listen
don't go to Stockton though
I've been there don't go back no
Stockton's great I just say it is a lot
going on out there man it's one of the
more active places in California
uh yeah the B there's a lot there's like
a lot of like uh just drama in Stockton
and then Brian Sampson the fat guy was
telling you about earlier he's from
there
yeah I can't understand where you're
coming from yeah but that I feel like
they what they got going is just for
them though like are you popping in the
bay right now because the bay is [__]
like Filipino like am I in America
Emma hey what's your big markets like
obviously like if you like when you look
at like Spotify where where would you
say your like biggest markets are like
where you most fans are
um to be honest like when I first like
blew up here in the states
like and when panalo like in terms of
demographically I was seeing a lot
definitely Philippines that's his
default of course and then here in the
US I was seeing New York
it was going crazy like in the first and
then
also Texas Texas
and then after that basically it started
like kind of fluctuating on different
scales of like the world than we saw we
was like the stats was going crazy in
Cambodia India dope so you got fans all
over the world and now you got you got
this Shady aftermath behind you words so
things are gonna get crazy for you yes
sir they're already getting crazy
um once you go like super crazy with the
hip-hop are you gonna do like a death
metal passion project
right into my mind like just like hey yo
I gotta
like even if it's just for me you guys
could like it or not but I gotta get
this one out like yeah probably like um
somewhere down the line because I gotta
I got all my homies that not just
because when I was still in the
Philippines I made homies like that's in
here in the states right like
collaborating with the metal stuff I
haven't even met them in person because
it's life just life's you know right who
your uh top five bands ever
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our good Folks at Blue
true baby that's right shout out to
Bluetooth man listen everyone's always
asking me does blue true work of course
it works because it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis it is
Dick season out here bruh you know what
I'm saying you got to make sure that
dick is up to par you know you get on
that blue shoe and uh you're gonna never
like I mean I'm gonna be honest like
do you remember when Barry Bonds hit 70
home runs in a season and now they're
not letting them in the Hall of Fame
like you get off that Bluetooth they're
not gonna let you in the dick Hall of
Fame because it's cheating to be honest
you know what I'm saying so
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
when you sign up now this is what's dope
about boochu because you want to know if
it works well they're going to send you
a month for free free Bluetooth in
discrete packaging delivered right to
your door but you have to use the promo
code bootleg bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg everything's online no doctor's
office visits no worrying about [__]
having a weird conversation with some
[__] about your [__] [__] no
you [__] bluetooth.com free month
online you don't even have to leave your
[__] apartment you don't have to
leave anywhere you just order it it
comes in the mail and then you know you
you just you know you get to work you
get to work all right so use that promo
code bootleg and get a free month of
blue chew also want to give a big shout
to our good Folks at Odd Socks now this
is what's up about Odd Socks I'm about
to reach into my Odd Socks bag
look Odd Socks they got
all of the [__] sick licenses
recently they locked down Coca-Cola
recently they locked down [__]
Transformers Saban Power Rangers we got
Yoo-hoo we got Sour Patch Kids
you know they got their Odd Socks Basics
and I'm telling you the most comfortable
socks in the world in the [__] world
all right and they can all be yours 20
off 20 off using the promo code bootleg
if you go to
oddsoxofficial.com the most comfortable
socks in the world
and they got draws and these draws are
amazing
these are this is this is a small just
so we're clear this is a small yeah
yeah chicks can wear this you know a lot
of chicks like wearing these booty
shorts around the crib and [__]
oddsocksofficial.com whatever you're
into they got the license WWE Scarface
[__] Breaking Bad whatever
autosofficial.com promo code bootleg go
over there get 20 off right now let's
get back to the interview
infinite annihilator
rings of Saturn
Arc spire
dying fetus
aborted there's a band called aborted
what the [__]
I'm gonna go listen can we let's listen
to this I'm aborted at our workout today
hey yo you gonna cook crazy what
especially if you get like with a good
job beforehand you get high and listen
to a board oh my gosh bro like it'll
separate the instruments the guitars is
here like like yeah it feel like you
best band name ever
aborted the best band name ever
um all right so uh obviously realist is
out with Eminem uh you got tons of music
videos tons of Music out
um you're working on new [__] you're
working on new visuals yep
um anything else you got coming you want
to shout out merch and any I mean you
just had a giant box of clothes
delivered and it was Revenge I thought
we were gonna get a sneak peek at the
new easy meal merch yeah shout out to
Revenge thanks for the cop bro this is
that's definitely right up your your
alley that one yeah this this looks
hella black metal today for sure yeah
that's black metal right there yeah
shout out to Black Metal Man now I gotta
go listen yo noodle was crazy because we
were talking about Norway right yeah
they even make like commercials like of
black metal bands promoting like soap
toothpaste really yeah
are these on YouTube wow
wow so they'll be like do us
yeah brush my teeth with this and then
sometimes they do it like so geniusly
like misleading first it's just like the
straight black metal like music video
you see and then at the end it's like
some Old Spice type I mean out there
that's kind of like their boy bands yeah
for real yo Nori's gotta be have you
been in Norway nope you gotta go man I
got I gotta see what's out there you
gotta go out there when you drop your
desk like uh Vikings came from I think
so
makes sense yeah then dudes like even
now if they didn't grow up as Vikings
their ancestors like we're Vikings
and they have to let it out which is
mentally okay with those parents like
sharing their kids stories yeah like and
then that leads to like you know your
dead band member on an album cover oh my
God
wait Melissa bad uh super excited for
you congratulations on everything man
thank you
um I can't wait to hear what uh the the
debut album on Shady aftermath sounds
like because that's a big deal yeah get
Richard I try and live up to
so
man there's gotta be a movie to it too I
got something planned but you gotta
you're gonna do visuals for the whole
[__] a movie to go along with everything
I like that
you're directing your own uh videos yes
sir that's dope I mean you've got your
hands all over the creative place you're
like a [__] Filipino Russ but but I
feel like it's like this new like wave
of artists like yeah us today in like my
generation like I feel like that's the
market now I mean if you're smart and
you're like with YouTube and the way
software's so easy to get for free if
you want to get it cracked
um like you can like really learn all of
it on your own yep or be at least good
enough to do all of it until you get to
a point where you can have someone else
do your [__] you know
yeah it turns it takes a certain type of
like situation I guess so like if you're
like surrounded with so much [__]
yeah and you like have nothing else to
do so you focus yeah learn [__] and you
can learn [__] on your phone YouTube
University man yes
go to YouTube learn everything like
whatever you can learn everything on
YouTube including how to um
you know how to knit knit
change the carburetor out
record your vocals see if the capacitor
is still working the capacitor
defibrillator you know what I mean
whatever that means anyway easy no I
appreciate you brother we're gonna do a
freestyle it's gonna be another video
you guys can check out uh go check out
the new record real estate just dropped
with Eminem and there's gonna be much
more coming from this guy yes sir boom
hey what up man uh you just watched
another episode of the bootleg cat
podcast brought to you by hard Dean baby
shout out to the family at hardean don't
forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land again
in that Uber say take me to hardine all
right they're gonna take get you taken
care of the most craziest Premium
Selection of cannabis you'll ever find
Under One Roof it's a vibe in there the
butt tenders they're gonna take care of
you man listen tell them I sent you
they're gonna get you right shout out to
the family at hardine in Las Vegas the
number one dispensary in the world all
right and we are so proud to be partners
with them so shout out to hardine go
follow them online Harding underscore
Las Vegas and check out their website
hardinglasvegas.com get you some swag
you know you can't buy this but you know
yeah shout out to hardine